maintenant faut dormir que
jesse n'aurait pas vu les clés
n'a pu cependant la main
reste la
bienvenue au paradis on est où là
tu veut traîner avec nous tu dois passer
une épreuve avant le seul truc que tu as
à faire c'est aller à l'intérieur
[Applaudissements]
c'est ici chez toi maintenant est-ce que
c'est clair
tu deviendras grand effort comme lui et
en a certains qui doivent laisser le mal
sorti il n'y a qu'à souffrance qui
peuvent évacuer la lumière c'est quoi
c'est pas les éclairages de noël mon
coeur il vous prévient avant de venir
nous torturer sauf que c'est pas lui qui
nous torture
[Musique]
moi je sortirai d'ici
qui te demandes si dont il on prendra
nos familles on peut ce super faut juste
qu'on soit malade
la veille ne repose que sur des choix
si tu n'as pas le choix
alors tu n'as rien